(crowd cheering)
- Okay,
so it's time to introduce our first guest.
And I dunno who it is.
I hope they like margaritas and quesos,
and if they don't,
leave. (chuckling)
(crowd laughs)
Please welcome the star of one
of my favorite shows on television.
Come on out, whoever you are.
(upbeat music)
(Kelly yells)
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd cheers)
I am so done.
Oh my gosh.
So basically, I'm on a date,
drinking with Nathan Fillion,
that's what's happening.
(crowd laughs)
I'm just kidding,
I'm just kidding.
- Are you surprised?
- I am.
I literally have nothing, no idea.
- We wanted to surprise you.
- Okay, okay.
- But I didn't want this
to be the only surprise.
- Oh, it's enough.
- Can I bring some more?
- Oh yeah.
Oh are you?
Please say, okay.
- I want you guys to all welcome,
please welcome, Mekia Cox.
- Yes.
- Alyssa Diaz, Melissa
O'Neil and Eric Winter.
- Yes.
(crowd cheering)
I am, I'm so excited.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
Oh my God.
How are you doing?
(crowd cheering)
All right, so Vic, would you
mind running over some chips,
and drinks to the entire
cast of The Rookie?
(hands clapping)
I'm so excited I'm sweating.
(Eric and Melissa laughing)
I'm sweating.
I have my drink.
- Thank you,
thank you very much.
- [Mekia] Unfortunately, I can't.
(Mekia chuckles)
- Oh my gosh, y'all,
don't dive into The Rookie unless you're
in for the long haul.
- Hello. (chuckling)
Thank you.
- [Kelly] It is so good.
- [Vic] You're welcome.
- [Nathan] Woo.
- I got so addicted.
I literally requested.
I love that you did this for my birthday.
I called my executive producer,
(Nathan chuckling)
I was like,
"Please, okay, I love Nathan,
I want the whole cast."
I was like, "Please get them on my show."
I love that you did it for my birthday.
Do y'all have so much fun with each other?
'Cause I know not every set can be
that magical with chemistry.
- We do.
We do have a lot of fun.
- And sometimes-
- You're such a hardass.
- to the extent that-
- I love it.
(Mekia laughs)
(crowd laughs)
Yes, okay, sorry, go, go.
- It's up to the extent
that when we're waiting
between takes and we're all hanging out,
we're taking too much
time to get back to set,
because we're talking, we're
laughing, we're playing games.
We play a lot of games.
- You play games?
- I feel bad for the directors,
because they come in and their job is to,
you know, get through the day,
get through all of their scenes.
But they usually have to add on,
when we're all there at the same time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They have to add on an hour to the day,
'cause they know that we're
gonna be talking, playing games.
- It can be a bit of chaos.
- Yeah.
- This is kind of-
- In a good way.
- They don't like scenes
with us together anymore.
We used to be in the roll
call room all the time.
And if you notice as the seasons go,
we're not in there as much anymore,
because we don't compare our days.
(Eric and Melissa laughs)
- Yes.
- Oh my God,
this is like me and my
friend Mary from childhood.
They separated us young.
They were like, "They
won't actually shut up."
So yeah but social.
(Alyssa laughs)
So what are everyone's
most memorable birthdays?
I'll start with you, Nathan.
- My most memorable birthday,
oh God, start with somebody
else, please, please.
(Kelly and Alyssa laughs)
- Okay, anybody right off the bat.
- My favorite birthday
was when I turned 30,
and my grandmother had recently passed,
and I heard this word. (chuckling)
Wow, I'm really going deep.
I heard this word I'd never
heard before, Hyperion.
And I was like, "I'm gonna look this up."
And Hyperion is one of
the tallest redwood trees.
And for that birthday I found it.
But you have to geolocate
it and it's not on a trail.
And so I was like wading
through this river.
Totally clear, you can see
all the way to the stones,
like carrying my sack over my bag.
Climbing over the redwood.
- What kind of movie
are you living in right now?
(crowd chuckling)
(Melissa laughs)
What?
- A good one.
- That's amazing.
(Melissa laughs)
- It's a Saturday thing. (chuckling)
- And you found it?
Are you that kind of person?
You're always adventurous like that?
- [Alyssa] Yes.
- Yeah, who doesn't love redwood trees?
- I am a nerd.
- (chuckling) Eric, Eric does.
I'm a total nerd.
- I love 'em, baby.
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd laughs)
- I'm more of a elm guy.
(Melissa laughs)
- Okay, now you have to
one up redwoods, Eric.
- [Eric] Well, I mean, yeah.
- What's
your favorite birthday?
- It's on my 27th birthday.
I planted a redwood tree.
(Kelly and crowd laughs)
And-
- No, you didn't.
Did you really?
- So I gave back
to mother earth.
- Yeah and then I turned 37
I climbed it and built
a house up there.
- I actually believed him
when he said he planted one.
And I planted another flower,
and had a tea ceremony up in tree.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
(Nathan laughing)
You are such a beautiful soul.
- I'm making distance.
- [Kelly] That was pretty
good comedic timing.
- [Eric] (chuckling) We can go with that.
- We can go with that. (laughing)
I like that. (chuckling)
What did you do?
You've had enough time, sir.
- Yes, I forgot all about it.
(crowd laughs)
I had gone nearly a decade
without having a party,
I had forgotten and someone said,
"It's time, you have to have a party now."
- Yeah, it's kind of stressful.
- It can be, yes, yes, yes.
But I had someone say,
"I'll take care of all the arrangements."
And I rented a restaurant,
I had like 350 people there.
Barbara Streisand showed up.
(crowd applauds)
(Melissa laughs)
- Who also has my birthday.
We're both April 24.
- What?
- [Kelly] Don't worry about it.
- Happy birthday, Barbara.
- Yeah, happy birthday, Barbara.
You and I,
we're just birthday sisters.
(Mekia laughs)
We have so much in common.
(Nathan laughing)
That's amazing.
Why did she randomly?
- Her wonderful husband came
and played my father on Castle,
I don't know if you remember that.
- Yes.
Do I remember?
Yes.
Still sexy as hell
- So he was invited,
he brought along his lovely wife,
and they both were there.
It was really-
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
(crowd cheers)
- Right?
We got on our thing.
- I love that your dad
ended up being like,
that was so amazing.
Thanks again for coming, I'm so excited.
- Thank you for having us.
(crowd cheers)
- I'm so excited.
- Thank you.
- I'm so excited you're all here.
So what's been your favorite?
Okay.
It's amazing, the show, like it goes,
and I love this about a show.
I feel like you love this about shows too,
'cause I've seen you in a lot of them.
But it's so diverse,
the show will touch on such emotional,
I mean, the part where you
were like, almost died,
and then the part with the
relationships, your ex,
there's so many layers.
Do y'all like that?
I feel like writers on sets are on shows,
don't always pay attention
to all the characters.
I just wanna give a shout out,
'cause the writers,
it really is important that the writers,
(hands clapping)
you really dive
into all the characters,
because you lose so
much opportunity there.
And there's an individual story
for each, whatever cultural background,
or whatever's your gender.
All of that.
- I will say, I was always surprised.
Like for example, she
was pregnant last year.
And so she had a lot,
they allowed her to
have a lot of days off.
Yet her character's story
was still really big.
You didn't didn't miss her at all.
And they're really, really good with that.
I don't know how they do that.
When with such a large cast,
how each character is equally important.
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm kind of smirking because my sister,
and I had a full on conversation
about how much we loved your
character pregnant. (chuckling)
Your emotions.
(Mekia laughs)
It was like, "I love the writers
who are making you like."
It's a really beautiful thing,
you just said and
everybody was freaked out,
'cause you were nice.
(Kelly laughs)
- Where else do you go?
You can't go more negative with her,
so they just-
(Mekia laughs)
- [Kelly] No, it was amazing.
It was so funny.
So Alyssa, so is there some
story about a banana peel?
That's what I'm supposed to ask.
- Oh.
- Yes.
- So the banana peel story.
So whenever Nathan has a banana,
he grabs banana peel,
and he throws it on the
floor, like a cartoon,
like someone's gonna slip on it.
But apparently I'm, I think,
the only one he does it in front of.
- I just-
- Oh, you thought this
was a thing he does?
- Yeah.
(Mekia laughing)
- I just toss it on the floor.
I go, "Hey, come here a second."
And I put it between us.
(Kelly laughs)
I go, "Hey, just come here a second."
That's all, that's all I do.
- Do you pick it up
or does someone fall?
- Of course I pick it up.
- No, he picks it up, he picks it up.
- I was like, "What kind
of jack?" (laughing)
(crowd laughs)
(Kelly laughing)
Okay, before we go to break,
I need to congratulate you on season five.
- Thank you very much.
(hands clapping)
(crowd cheering)
- I loved y'all so much
for doing this show.
I literally texted my producer.
I was like, "Please get them on my show."
And I love that it was for my birthday.
- [Nathan] You know,
something that's been
brought to our attention.
You're no stranger to television work.
We've seen your work.
- Jesus.
- [Nathan] Your acting work.
- I hate acting.
(Mekia laughing)
- On Sabrina the teenage witch.
(Kelly laughs)
- Wait, that was paying bills. (chuckling)
- [Nathan] Can we go to the clip, please?
- [Mekia] Roll the clip.
- [Kelly] In my defense,
my roommate was an actor.
- [Mekia] Oh there it is.
- [Nathan] Here we go, here we go.
Who's that?
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's me.
(crowd applauds)
You know what that is?
That's fifty dollars. (chuckling)
- [Nathan] First of all,
you're extremely talented,
I love how you're looking
right down the barrel,
right at the camera.
(Melissa and Eric laughs)
That's amazing.
- I was supposed
to be looking at her.
- That takes a lot of courage,
that takes a lot of courage.
- I was supposed to be looking at her.
- But we think that if
you would do us the honor
of taking some of that talent
and bringing it to our show.
(crowd cheers)
- Oh my God, are you serious?
You guys, I'm a horrible actor.
Can I just walk by and do this?
(Mekia laughs)
- We're gonna find you
something you're really good at.
We're gonna find something.
- Just have me playing Kelly Clarkson.
I'm really, really bad at acting.
(Nathan laughs)
Okay, time, I'm sweating right now,
but I'm totally in just so I can hang out.
Time for another commercial break.
Everybody, you can see The Rookie,
Sundays on ABC or
streaming anytime on Hulu
in my living room.